it's hard to get up to the Alpine chalet
in winter snow can be more than a meter
deep for months here on Mount catch bag
at 1,650 meters above sea level in the
Austrian state of Corinthian carpenter
installer inherited the 400 year old
Chalet from his ancestors and restored
it painstakingly by hand
according to age-old tradition for your
feet is same as it used to be a cabin
where herdsmen could cook and sleep
simply as protection from wind rain and
weather the ground floor consists of a
single large room dominated by the
dining table and the small kitchen in
the corner plus a huge fireplace which
is the heart of the chalet and keeps the
entire house warm
[Music]
this Hedison but as heating was
essential because where there is no
warmth there is no life the stoves in
the chalets were always located very
centrally in the kitchen in the living
area and to make sure were very little
warmth was lost that's why the windows
were very small back then this becomes
your guns clearly feels like more Alpine
mountain dwellers can teach us how to
organise life in the tightest of spaces
every free surface is used for storage
[Music]
there's a wooden lattice above the stove
for hanging out washing and the dining
table with its splayed legs offers room
for everyone the shakes too is this hope
the frame was built with slanted legs so
people would have room for their legs
when they sent their devious own the
shoe blow the drawer is very special the
shoe blood most drawers were made of
Swiss pine because the essential oils in
the wood repelled vermin on he can only
tea for two
the many loving details are another
reason and Starla and his wife Ulrika
feel so comfortable in this Alpine
chalet
the walls have decorative patterns
carved into the plaster
[Music]
Beaupre khattala has hung dried herbs
everywhere this is loving this is
lavender it has a calming effect if the
scent is too intense for some people
they can remove it but I find it very
soothing for maybe exponent when n
Starla took over the chalet it was very
rundown except for the 17th century
wooden beams little in the interior was
still intact then I started to restore
everything I tried to preserve the old
features and supplement them with new
ones to against him he spruced up the
bathroom with stones he found in the
mountain pastures and he converted the
old stable facing the chalet
into a sauna
[Music]
in the chalets upper story there are
three simple bedrooms but in the winter
it's better only to sleep in the one
that's right above the stove on the
ground floor or the bedroom for the
parents with their small children was
always above the kitchen because heat
rises and that way they and their
children could keep warm
I'll give you CVMA but an Stannah feels
best on the balcony from here he has a
glorious view of the catch bags winter
landscape
roofed fresh air water and trees are
really important to me provide grounding
for me I'm at home here that's life for
me I calm down and I'm at peace this is
the Alpine chalet on the catch bag a
place where you can live comfortably
even in the severus of winters far from
civilization in complete harmony with
nature
[Music]